you you see that show swarm on Amazon I
did see it I did that show is crazy
crazy ass show what do you watch on TV
what are your go-to I like like murder
mystery of course you
do is it sexist to say that like why is
that a woman thing like every woman
loves that kind of [__] it might be like
sexist it's a little sexist but it's
also men are [__] that's why there it
is but isn't that not
look my wife all her friends everybody I
know they all my my mom oh my god when
my mom and my wife get together they're
just [__] binge watching serial
killer [__] yes I love it shitty
reenactments with shitty actors oh wow
they're interviewing the the detectives
the F it's just yeah I like stuff like
that where I like um I like this show
called suits right now I don't suits
that's got the girl who the the uh
what's Megan Mar in it right yeah yes
she's phenomenal cuz that's like an
older show that kind of just repoed
right on Netflix like it stopped in like
2017 I want to say good though yeah I
really like show like like that mhm I
like I like stuff like that suits gry's
Anatomy um what's the other one um with
Matthew GRE
gobler that I can't think of [__]
sick name right
there I can't think of the show name but
people going did you watch Scandal I
show like scand Scandal was fire yeah
shout out to her she's she's lovely for
sure man what was her name on the show
Olivia Olivia Pope yes the fixer yeah I
you know I don't ever want to be like
successful enough to where I would need
to hire someone like
her that's real as [__] cuz Livia Pope
was just getting her hands dirty bro
like I'm like I don't want to be that
important to ever have to call like
Olivia you know what I'm saying like
real [__] that's
some yeah that's just another level of
uh yeah yeah shout out to Olivia po well
is is it about being successful is it
cuz you [__] up I don't know doing
dumb [__] I don't know bro that's why
you call Olivia cuz you doing stupid
[__] that is true and then she was I
kind of had like I was like she's in the
white guys you know that's somebody
who's a Caucasian who's into melanated
women I was
like I was like hell yeah hey the
president taking that [__] down bro
let's go oh my God is that is that is
that like is that like a niche thing is
that like no I mean I I just I so I'm
married to a Mexican woman and my kids
are half Mexican I just don't I'm not
into any I'm not into white women at all
they're kind of like I just don't they
just remind me of like my family you
know like I don't want to [__] somebody
who looks like my cousin you know like
right right so I understand so also like
white women are like it's like when you
go to the candy aisle and like there's
all the packs of M&M's right he's about
to say some real crazy misogynistic sex
no no no no no so like a white woman is
like you get the brown pag of M&M's and
like nobody wants the brown bag of M&M's
you want the yellow bag when they got
the peanut butter ones you want like no
one's doing plain M&M's unless it's all
they got you know what I'm saying like
so I kind of damn and I'm I'm just damn
he just white woman like a t-shirt but
hey but listen I'm also a plain
Eminem yeah I'm a white man so I also
I'm in I'm I'm like an Eminem mini in
the little tube you
know I just I prefer mine you know I
like I like some peanuts in MY M&M's you
know or some yeah little flavor what
just a little flavor just a little
little flavor it's like and like white
women can't cook like my mom can't cook
you know like she could cook enough like
so what does that look like when growing
up with like a mom that can't cook what
do you well listen listen I my mom can
cook enough but she's listen
Thanksgiving at my house versus
Thanksgiving at my wife's family's house
there's just a lot more seasoning
obviously yeah shout out to my mom and
my aunt and my sister they can't cook
for [__] damn I mean they can cook like
they're here's food you know but it's
like is it like great like right like my
dad can cook better than my mom my dad
Cooks way better than my mom is your dad
white yeah but he's like hillbilly white
so I feel like it's a little different
they got a little more like I don't know
like he'll he'll put like he'll like uh
make this I'm bacon grease yeah or he'll
have a roast and he like marinates the
roast in Coca-Cola for like 12 hours and
that [__] is gas [__] that it's also
it's it's fire hell no it's really good
I don't want nothing marinated in no
Coca-Cola you don't drink soda I don't
drink Coca-Cola what do you
drink if you had to drink of soda I like
back the Peppa y Coke is the wave hell
no if you're going to pick a
soda I like salsa you like a Seltzer
like a white claw or like a more like
regular like just like seltzer water
yeah oh yeah that's gross what a black
cherry salsa fire I'm good I like it cuz
sometimes we just need the bubbles just
a little bubble yeah it's like a fake
soda exactly so you'll do like a what's
the thing called lro lro I'll do a lroy
yeah that's fine I mean it's much
healthier than like the high fructose
cart syrup that's in all the Coca-Cola
that I drink Mex Mexican Coke's the wave
m in the bottle right straight cane
sugar it's real
[__] it is I don't know